vous n'avez jamais eu la sensation votre
place était ailleurs que vous aviez
autre chose à accomplir
dites-moi que vous n'avez jamais vu mon
visage
j'étais dans le train il y a eu une
explosion
et puis je me souvenais plus de rien
sauf de fou
vous étiez une espionne comme moi
j'aurais dit vous voyez ce que vous
savez faire pour être
déjà fait dans un rêve
vous faisiez partie d'une légende vous
faisiez partie de citadelle une agence
d'espionnage qui n'obéit à aucun
gouvernement
il y a 8 ans nous avons été trahis par
l'un des nôtres
nous changeons l'ordre du monde
ce n'est qu'une question de temps
entendu à présent j'ai besoin de votre
aide qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est la
seule solution
il ne doit jamais la prendre
[Musique]
vous devez vous souvenir du passé
pour sauver le futur
[Musique]
vous êtes prêts
je vois que vous m'avez offert de
nouveaux jouets spécialement pour mon
agent préféré Youssouf qui ne lui ont
pas plus mais je ne voulais pas le jeter
alors salut